new technology is transforming the way
we pay for things mobile transactions
worldwide are expected to top 721
billion dollars this year as customers
and businesses turn away from cash in a
recent survey nearly 75 percent of
shoppers expect mobile payments to grow
in the next three to five years
Robert Safian is editor and Managing
Director of the monthly business
magazine Fast Company joins us now good
morning good morning so why are we
getting away from using cash well first
of all there are restaurants and places
now that won't let you right yeah right
they want you to do this part of it is
we have these devices with us all the
time everywhere we are right and we have
our wallets with us they may be in our
pocket or in our bag but they're not out
and a part of us the same way right and
so businesses are trying and as
consumers were more comfortable using
them all the time
we see it on airplanes as well it
definitely is convenient is there any
downside I guess for consumers well
there are risks with some of it there
are there are risks for certain privacy
issues if you're paying for everything
with your phone as opposed to with cash
you can be tracked right and there is
the fear or the question about
electronic fraud right identity fraud
things can be stolen listen the reason
restaurants part of the reason they want
you to pay just by credit card is they
don't have to worry about cash they have
to worry about robberies but there are
electronic thieves that are out there
also and these are these are two
different sides of it you know Robert
one of the things that people worry
about is it's easier to spend when all
you're doing is hitting that little
thumbprint on your iPhone and boom
you've just bought something you know
when cash is flying out of your hand you
can actually say oh I'm spending a big
time I think this has been a situation
that we've been talking about since the
start of credit cards right there comes
easier to pay when you're not thinking
about the cash itself but this is a
continuation of the same kinds of things
technological changes from credit cards
to ATMs
this genie is not going back in the box
if the reason it happens it's easier
it's easier for for retailers it's
easier for us as consumers we like it
you look at a peer-to-peer networks like
venmo or now Apple has Apple pay cash
right and the reason people are using it
is you want to split the cost of a gift
for your grandmother you can do it you
know via a text it's very very easy is
it generational though oh I think it has
started with Millennials certainly you
grow up with these devices with these
phones that you want to use them that
way that's natural to have to have
happen but Apple is not including this
across this platform just to reach a
small group of people right this is
something that that's not going to
change now there are groups of people
who are left out in this if you are part
of the unbanked part of our population
it means that there's establishments and
economic activity that you can't
participate in and so that is one of the
the societal challenges that we have to
deal with as this proliferation of
mobile payments continues and this is a
global trend right we're seeing this
across absolutely all over the world
wherever are you doing in Sweden in
China wherever people are more connected
to their phones and doing more
activities on their phone and more
economic activity you're gonna see more
and more of this it's not gonna change
it's really interesting yeah how about
the impact overall on the economy though
as we do this is there a change not
using cash for for businesses and banks
the reason they want to do is there are
a lot of transactions when you use your
credit card the credit card company the
bank makes a small piece of money right
right and so all of these cash
transactions they're not making money on
so this is that this is part of the
reason why the banks are pushing into
this area because and technology
companies are using it as a way to
themselves get into the banking business
get into that part of the transaction so
venmo the peer-to-peer network is owned
by PayPal if you bought PayPal stock
earlier this year you're very happy
ninety percent this year like Bitcoin
how does they don't start tacking on
fees every time you use these phones or
these mobile technology yes you don't
necessarily see the fees that are buried
inside that is one of the champion
though yeah it's a fear there's always
my friend thank you very much thanks
good to see you